Saturn’s rings are iconic, but up close
they’re less like thin rings and more like
perfectly ordered zones of terror.
Saturn’s rings -- identified by letters
according to their date of discovery -- are
made of chunks of ice and rock with pieces
ranging in size from a grain of sand to a
house.
Which means the rings aren’t as thin as
we make them in our grade school models of
the solar system.
If you’ve ever seen Saturn through a telescope
and the rings seem to disappear, it’s just
because you’re seeing them head on from
about 746 million miles (1.2 billion kilometers)
away.
And they’re relatively thin compared to
Saturn.
At various points the rings range from between
about 30 to 300 feet thick (9m–91m), while
Saturn’s diameter is around the order of
72,000 miles (116,500km), which is a little
more than 18 times larger than Earth’s.
But if you look at a picture of Saturn from
above you can see that the rings have a massive
diameter — which makes sense since they
circle around the planet’s equator.
The rings, combined, stretch 175,000 miles
(282,000 kilometers) from Saturn.
And they aren't totally solid.
Each ring is made of multiple rings that you
can see close up.
As for origin, astronomers think they’re
related to Saturn’s more than 60 moons.
Asteroids and meteoroids sometimes crash into
the smaller moons, breaking them apart and
adding material to the rings.
But some of the material might be left over
from when Saturn formed, material that never
became a moon!Some moons also play a vital
part in keeping the rings distinct.
The rings aren’t static — they orbit around
Saturn like its moons do, and at least two
moons around the narrow F ring keeps it in
check.
The gravity of Pandora stops the F ring from
spreading outward while Prometheus prevents
it from spreading inward.
Other shepherd moons keep other rings in check
and constrain how they spread out.
They're also responsible for some odd structures.
Some rings have features called propellers,
spaces caused by tiny moonlets that open gaps.
Other rings have spoke-looking things that
are caused by conglomerations of tiny ice
particles that rise above the ring’s surface
by electrostatic charge.
So next time you’re looking at Saturn keep
in mind that the rings aren’t just pretty,
they’re also chunks of ice and rock, in
constant change, chaotically hurtling through
space.
Isn’t that more fun to imagine, anyway?
If you’re a total space nut, why not start
your own website cataloguing your favourite
planetary facts!
When you buy a domain name from Domain.com,
you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a .com or .net domain name.
Get 20% off Domain.com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Want more science in your day?
Subscribe to Seeked for all the latest videos!
And speaking of Saturn’s moons, Julian talks
about the potential for life on Enceladus
right here.
And my favourite fun fact?
The rings are super cold!
They can get down to minus 333.4 degrees Fahrenheit
(minus 203 degrees Celsius) on the unlit side!